[Applauso]
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
wow oh mamma è anche il mantra della
felicità
secondo voi siete così entusiasti quando
noi siamo davvero felici i nostri
trilioni di cellule che compongono i
nostri corpi umani i tempi della nostra
anima davvero esultano e sprigioniamo
benessere ovunque
oggi sono qui per parlarvi di un qualche
cosa di veramente straordinario per le
nostre vite umane
sono qui per parlarvi di capi genetica
oltre 20 anni fa quando ero ancora un
giovane ragazzo accade qualcosa di
veramente molto difficile nella mia vita
mio babbo si ammalò di una grave
malattia e le sue ultime parole prima di
lasciare il suo corpo furono si sempre
felice certo non è assolutamente facile
per una persona che perde un proprio
caro essere felici ma devo dirvi che è
stato grazie a quella esperienza così
traumatica così dolorosa che mi ha dato
la possibilità di ricercare davvero
quale fosse il senso della felicità o
anche l'utilità dell'essere felice per
questo motivo vi ad entrare nel mondo
della meditazione dello yoga pratica i
mindfulness addirittura con la mia
famiglia decisi di trasferirmi nella mia
amata india nel centro sud dell'india a
puttaparthi e provavo a meditare provavo
ad essere sereno inca calmo in pace con
me stesso ma la felicità non la sentivo
ma è dentro di me un giorno non per caso
ma per serendipità feci una scoperta
davvero straordinaria scopri il potere
terapeutico della risata ogni giorno al
mattino alle pad e 30
oltre a meditare praticavo in solitudine
la risata incondizionata e più ridevo
più le mie cellule ridevano con me più
ridevo più un atteggiamento mentale
cambiava come disse il grande william
james ogni essere umano un grande
potenziale quello di trasformare la
propria vita cambiando il proprio
atteggiamento mentale
cambiando le proprie abitudini non solo
continua a ridere da solo ma portare la
terapia della risata persino negli
orfanotrofi negli ospedali nelle aziende
nei villaggi sperduti del sud dell'india
che cosa osservai il cambiamento
radicale nella vita nei volti delle
persone che empaticamente sorridevano
ridevano assieme a me c'è una branca
della scienza molto importante direi o
andar straordinaria che studia quanto le
circostanze esterne possono cambiare la
nostra genetica vi sto parlando di
epigenetica il nostro codice epigenetico
è molto importante perché è quello che
ci permette di sopravvivere di
relazionarci nell'ambiente nel quale noi
viviamo
sappiamo ad esempio che la dieta
alimentare e influisce nella nostra
genetica ma anche le nostre emozioni
oggi più che mai siamo troppo stressati
e questo purtroppo danneggia
irrimediabilmente in alcuni casi la
nostra salute il nostro benessere e non
ce lo possiamo permettere perché essere
felici è una grande responsabilità
sociale attraverso gli studi
approfonditi dell'epigenetica ho potuto
osservare come le nostre emozioni hanno
davvero il potere di cambiare non solo
il nostro main set ma addirittura la
qualità delle nostre vite dall
epigenetica alla happy genetica ma che
cos'è la happy genetica sono tutte
quelle abitudini felici che noi giorno
dopo giorno dovremmo implementare nella
nostra vita quelle abitudini che ti
permettono di percepire questa energia
straordinaria curativa terapeutica
l'energia della felicità meditare ridere
profondo rilassamento sono alcune delle
basi straordinarie che fondono
l'epigenetica come sicuramente saprete
quando noi ridiamo naturalmente abbiamo
il potere di trasformare la nostra
giornata e anche le giornate di chi vive
accanto a noi come ci ricorda la scienza
quando noi ridiamo il nostro corpo
alcune parti del nostro corpo il nostro
cervello sprigionano queste sostanze
chimiche
kimi che la chimica della felicità
quando tu ridi scatena nel tuo corpo una
dose di sana felicità dose è l'acronimo
che sta per dopamina ossitocina
serotonina ed endorfine
vi rendete conto quando ci lasciamo
ridere il nostro corpo gioisce grazie a
questa chimica e la risalta a questa
virtù terapeutica addirittura di
trasmutare il tuo codice epigenetico vi
ricordate quando è stata l'ultima volta
che avete riso in qualche ambito
lavorativo in famiglia beh naturalmente
sono stato invitato qui come speaker per
aiutarvi a lasciarvi ridere vi va di
farlo assieme a me ok un semplice
esercizio
mi raccomando fatemi fare bella figura
braccia in avanti portiamo le braccia
verso di noi e inspiriamo inspiring
spirit l'attività tiri fuori la risata
se non mi vien da ridere perché state
pensando vostra suocera
lasciatevi ridere con il manto della
felicità prova a non preoccupatevi il
corpo dicono gli scienziati non è in
grado di riconoscere quando una risata è
spontanea o con quando è spontanea
pertanto ridiamo che è meglio proviamo
braccia in avanti portiamo nel verso di
noi fraternità tin.it a tenere di
bravissimi ultima volta inspiriamo tra
tv tadini tatini adesso ridi e adesso
fai un applauso al tuo sorriso alla tua
risata camorra
[Applauso]
certo certo
la scienza afferma che per sprigionare
questa dose di sana chimica della
felicità dovremmo ridere addirittura per
15 minuti
e questa è la mia missione aiutare le
persone a rilasciare questa
straordinaria energia ma una delle basi
fondamentali della happy genetica è in
grado cioè e questa è una notizia
davvero molto importante di cambiare la
nostra struttura genetica e soprattutto
quando noi
intercettiamo quelle emozioni positive
che ci onorano di essere degli esseri
umani
voglio fare un esperimento qui con voi
se vi va
vi chiedo ora di chiudere per qualche
istante i vostri occhi
e mentre continua a parlare
vi chiedo di portare la vostra
attenzione centro del petto
quello che viene definito il chakra del
cuore
quando noi ridiamo migliora la nostra
salute
si abbassa lo stress
soprattutto diamo la possibilità alle
nostre emozioni trattenute di essere
rilasciate e questo ci permette davvero
di vivere una vita degna di essere
vissuta
ora che la vostra attenzione di centro
del petto
vi chiedo di iniziare a percepire con il
potere della vostra immaginazione
questi raggi di luce dorata
inizia a percepire questa energia
straordinaria e inizia a sviluppare
questo senso di profonda gratitudine per
ogni sua singola cellula trillioni di
cellule che compongono il tuo corpo
umano sviluppa gratitudine per tutti gli
organi che ti permettono di vivere
questa vita straordinaria
percepisci questi raggi di luce dorata
inizia donare attraverso la tua
gratitudine
questa sensazione di amore di pace a
tutte le persone che tu anni
immagina di avvolgerle di abbracciare i
tuoi cari tono loro gratitudine per
essere presenti nella tua vita
per rendere la tua vita così preziosa
continua ad alimentare questa energia e
immagina ancora di avvolgere anche i
tuoi cari amici i due amiche ma anche i
tuoi colleghi di lavoro
permette a questa energia straordinaria
di farti percepire il senso di
appartenenza unità nella diversità
e ora ti chiedo di a diventare questi
raggi luminosi piene di energia positiva
e dona a questa energia
soprattutto elementi
malate che sono presenti oggi su questo
pianeta terra permette a questa energia
straordinaria di trasformare la loro
energia e farli sentire parte di questa
grande famiglia che l'umanità
e ancora finito ora a bocce questa
energia straordinaria
il pianeta terra baciava ma gaia che ti
permette di realizzare la tua vita
i tuoi sogni
di sperimentare ciò che tu sei
percepisci
questo meraviglioso senso di appartenere
l'unità nella diversità
e ora di fido
immediatamente di appoggiare entrambe le
mani centro del petto sacro cuore
e ora ti chiedo di sperimentare profonda
gratitudine ad una persona davvero
wonder meravigliosa senza la quale tutto
questo non potrebbe essere sperimentato
e questa persona degna di essere amata
sei tu e ora delicatamente riaprire gli
occhi e donati di quell'applauso che
nessuno mai via donato fatelo ora con
voi stessi
poco fa fare
obama
la vita è una questione di scelte e
saper scegliere
è catturare dei migliori opportunità la
felicità è una scelta che oggi noi siamo
tremendamente meravigliosamente
fortunati perché possiamo scegliere di
vivere licata le abitudini impedisci e
di sperimentare il meglio nelle nostre
vite
la tua vita dipende unicamente dalle tue
scelte quali sono dei centri migliori
sono quelle scelte che impattano con il
tuo benessere fisico mentale emozionale
spirituale hai scelto bene tutte le
volte che mette a disposizione la tua
vita al servizio degli altri della
collettività delle persone che ogni
giorno incontri su questo straordinario
pianeta terra
sì se è qui sei ricevuto questo dono tra
straordinario della vita sei qui per
dare il tuo migliore di contributo
il nome della felicità l'espressione
tetra gioia è il nostro vero dna
pensiamo tutti qui per riconoscere che
oggi non che mai
anziché cercare cittadini esemplari
la nostra grande opportunità e di essere
quell esempio è l'esempio è quello di
donare
giornata mente e il nostro amore ovunque
a chiunque attraverso il nostro servizio
attraverso il nostro sorriso alto adesso
la nostra straordinaria risata sui
davvero site benissimo
fatelo sentire le vostre certi e
soprattutto quando tornerete a carta
abbracciato i vostri cari e dite loro
sono grato che tutta la vita in un
sorriso è permesso
[Musica]